[Music]  what's up disney plus  i for one couldn't be more proud of  loki's newfound career success  at the tva in marvel studios loki  inspired by his example i'm here to  share a few  foolproof tricks to land and thrive at  your dream job  here we go first and foremost always  show up  on time with a smile on your face  next win the approval of your superiors  big metaphor guy  i love it makes you sound super smart i  am smart  i know okay okay greet each new task  with enthusiasm please sign to verify  this is everything you've ever said  this is absurd respect the chain of  command it is adorable  that you think you could possibly  manipulate me and above all  remain honest and trustworthy i've  studied almost every moment of your  entire life  you've literally stabbed people in the  back like 50 times  why never do it again be sure to check  out all these shining examples and more  in marvel studios loki the original  series  now streaming on disney plus  you